former Chinese president Jiang semin has
died at the age of 96 according to State
media
he came to power in the wake of the
repression of the pro-democracy protests
in Tiananmen Square in 1989.
he steered China through economic reform
that transformed the country into a
global manufacturing Powerhouse
he also oversaw the return of Hong Kong
from the UK in 1997 and Macau from
Portugal in 1999.
Jiang stepped down as president in 2003
but remained influential in the ruling
Communist Party long after he retired
and let's get more on this we are joined
by DW reporter Clifford coonen who
worked as a correspondent in China for
many years how important a figure was he
in Chinese history well he was a very
important figure in those years in China
it was constantly being reported that
John zimin was dead so this has finally
be confirmed he was an emblematic figure
of change in China in many ways he
oversaw some of the biggest events in
Chinese history and in some ways created
the kind of China which Xi Jinping the
current leader has inherited
particularly with accession to the uh
the World Trade Organization in the
early 2000s the process which continued
over the early 2000s and um he he
basically was a transitional figure in
some ways because uh Xi Jinping has now
become this enormous figure but uh his
his position in history and Chinese
history is certainly assured how do
citizens of China see him well he was
funny in some ways he was he was more
charismatic than a lot of Chinese
leaders who tend to be technocrats
um he was famous for his rendition of
Love Me Tender he could recite the
Gettysburg address in English which was
pretty remarkable
um he when you'd go to Shanghai he was
very very popular in Shanghai which was
his power base and taxi drivers always
had stories about him and and then you
come into the hujin tower era after that
and the stories end and the technocrats
come in and now we have Xi Jinping who
courses another stage in some ways of
communist rule in China and that he's
um very much Hardline the Communist
Party figure not to say the Zhang's men
didn't oversee his own share of um of of
events that were controversial including
the Crackdown on the falun gong movement
uh the spiritual movement which was led
to a lot of people being arrested and
killed do we know what he thought of Xi
Jinping
um he he was a I think he was a skeptic
because he led the Shanghai faction
which uh was supposedly in opposition to
um to XI jinping's faction
um at the party Congress last year he he
very pointedly had a large
um magnifying glass and he he was kept
looking at his watch during XI jinping's
speech and things like that he he was
sort of they were they were they were
Rivals but at the same time they both
believed in keeping the party strong so
they they couldn't express it too
obviously but they they were definitely
Rivals okay Clifford coonan uh joining
us with this news Chong semen has died
at the age of 96. thank you so much